The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MEHRAN KARDAR: You
decide at first look
at the our simple system,
which was the ideal gas.
And imagine that we
have this gas contained
in a box of volume V that
contains N particles.
And it's completely isolated
from the rest of the universe.
So you can know the amount
of energy that it has.
So the macroscopic
description of the system
consists of these three
numbers, E, V, and N.
And this was the characteristics
of a microcanonical ensemble
in which there was no
exchange of heat or work.
And therefore,
energy was conserved.
And our task was somehow to
characterize the probability
to find the system
in some microstate.
Now if you have N
particles in the system,
there is at the microscopic
level, some microstate that
consists of a description of
all of the positions of momenta.
And there is
Hamiltonian that governs
how that microstate evolves
as a function of time.
And for the case of ideal gas,
the particles don't interact.
So the Hamiltonian can be
written as the sum of n terms
that describe essentially
the energy of the end
particle composed of
its kinetic energy.
And the term that is really
just confining the particle
is in this box.
And so the volume of
the box is contained.
Let's say that in
this potential,
that it's zero inside the
box and infinity outside.
And we said, OK, so given that
I know what the energy, volume,
number of particles
are, what's the chance
that I will find the system
in some particular microstate?
And the answer was
that, obviously, you
will have to put zero if the
particles are outside box.
Or if the energy, which is
really just the kinetic energy,
does not much the energy that
we know is in the system,
we sum over i of P
i squared over 2m
is not equal to the
energy of the system.
Otherwise, we say that if
the microstate corresponds
to exactly the right
amount of energy, then
I have no reason to exclude it.
And just like saying
that the dice can
have six possible
faces, you would
assign all of those possible
phases equal probability.
I will give all of
the microstates that
don't conflict
with the conditions
that I have set out
the same probability.
I will call that
probability 1 over
some overall constant omega.
And so this is one otherwise.
So then the next
statement is well
what is this number omega
that you have put it?
And how do we determine it?
Well, we know that this
P is a probability so
that if I were to integrate
over the entirety of the face
space of this probability,
the answer should be 1.
So that means this
omega, which is
a function of these parameters
that I set out from the outside
to describe the
microstate, should
be obtained by integrating over
all q and p of this collection
of 1s and 0s that
I have out here.
So I think this box of
1s and 0s, put it here,
and I integrate.
So what do I get?
Well, the integration
over the q's is easy.
The places that I get 1 are
when the q's are inside the box.
So each one of them will
give me a factor of V.
And there are N of them.
So I would get V to the N.
The integrations over
momenta essentially
have to do with seeing whether
or not the condition sum
over i Pi squared over 2m
equals to E is satisfied or not.
So this I can write
also as sum over i
P i squared equals to 2mE,
which I can write as R squared.
And essentially, in
this momentum space,
I have to make sure that the
sum of the components of all
of the momenta squared
add up to this R. squared,
which as we discussed
last time, is
the surface of hypershpere
in 3N dimensions of radius
R, which is square root of 2mE.
So I have to integrate
over all of these momenta.
And most of the
time I will get 0,
except when I heat the
surface of this sphere.
There's kind of a little
bit of singularity
here because you have a
probability that there's 0,
except at the very sharp
interval, and then 0 again.
So it's kind of like a delta
function, which is maybe
a little bit hard to deal with.
So sometimes we
will generalize this
by adding a little
bit be delta E here.
So let's say that the energy
does not have to be exactly E,
but E minus plus
a little bit, so
that when we look at
this surface in three
n dimensional space--
let's say this was two
dimensional space--
rather than having
to deal with an
exact boundary, we
have kind of smoothed that
out into an interval that
has some kind of a thickness
R, that presumably is related
to this delta E
that I put up there.
Turns out it doesn't
really make any difference.
The reason it doesn't
make any difference I
will tell you shortly.
But now when I'm integrating
over all of these
P's-- so there's P. There's
another P. This could be P1.
This could be P2.
And there are
different components.
I then get 0, except
when I hit this interval
around the surface
of this hypersphere.
So what do I get as a result
of the integration over this 3N
dimensional space?
I will get the volume
of this element, which
is composed of the
surface area, which
has some kind of a solid
angle in 3N dimensions.
The radius raised to
the power of dimension
minus 1, because it's a surface.
And then if I want to
really include a delta R
to make it into a volume, this
would be the appropriate volume
of this interval
in momentum space.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just to
clarify, you're
asserting that
there's no potential
inside the [INAUDIBLE] that
comes from the hard walls.
MEHRAN KARDAR: Correct.
We can elaborate
on that later on.
But for the description of the
ideal gas without potential,
like in the box, I have
said that potential
to be just 0 infinity.
OK?
OK, so fine.
So this is the description.
There was one
thing that I needed
to tell you, which is the d,
dimension, of solid angle,
which is 2pi to the
d over 2 divided
by d over 2 minus 1
factorial So again,
in two dimensions, such as the
picture that I drew over here,
the circumference of a
circle would be 2 pi r.
So this s sub 2--
right there'd be 2 pi--
and you can show that
it is 2 pi divided
by 0 factorial, which is 1.
In three dimensions it should
give you 4 pi r squared.
Kind of looks
strange because you
get 2 pi to the 3/2 divided
by 1/2 half factorial.
But the 1/2 factorial
is in fact root 2
over pi-- root pi over 2.
And so this will work out fine.
Again, the definition of
this factorial in general
is through the gamma
function and an integral
that we saw already.
And factorial is the integral
0 to infinity, dx, x to the n
into the minus x.
Now, the thing is that
this is a quantity that
for large values of dimension
grows exponentially v E d.
So what I claim is that if I
take the log of this surface
area and take the limit that
d is much larger than 1,
the quantity that I
will get-- well, let's
take the log of this.
I will get log of 2.
I will get d over 2 log
pi and minus the log
of this large factorial.
And the log of the factorial
I will use Sterling's formula.
I will ignore in
that large limit
the difference between d
over 2 and d over 2 minus 1.
Or actually I guess
at the beginning
I may even write it d over 2
minus 1 log of d over 2 minus 1
plus d over 2 minus 1.
Now if I'm in this
limit of large d again,
I can ignore the 1s.
And I can ignore the log 2
with respect to this d over 2.
And so the answer in this
limit is in fact proportional
to d over 2.
And I have the log.
I have pi.
I have this d over 2 that
will carry in the denominator.
And then this d over 2 times 1
I can write as d over 2 log e.
And so this is
the answer we get.
So you can see that the
answer is exponentially large
if I were to again write s of d.
S of d grows like
an exponential in d.
OK, so what do I
conclude from that?
I conclude that s over Kd--
and we said that the entropy,
we can regard as the entropy of
this probability distribution.
So that's going to give
me the log of this omega.
And log off this omega,
we'll get a factor
from this v to the n.
So I will get N
log V. I will get
a factor from log of S of 3N.
I figured out what that
log was in the limit
of large dimensions.
So I essentially have 3N over 2
because my d is now roughly 3N.
It's in fact exactly 3N, sorry.
I have the log of 2 pi e.
For d I have 3N.
And then I actually
have also from here
a 3N log R, which I can write
as 3N over 2 log of R squared.
And my R squared is 2mE.
The figure I have here.
And then you say, OK,
we added this delta R.
But now you can
see that I can also
ignore this delta R, because
everything else that I have
in this expression is
something that grows radially
with N. What's the worse
that I can do for delta R?
I could make delta R even as big
as the entirety of this volume.
And then the
typical volume would
be of the order of the energy--
sorry, the typical value of R
would be like the
square root of energy.
So here I would
have to put this log
of the square root
of the energy.
And log of a square roots
of an extensive quantity
is much less than the
extensive quantity.
I can ignore it.
And actually this reminds me,
that some 35 years ago when
I was taking this course,
from Professor Felix Villiers,
he said that he
had gone to lunch.
And he had gotten to this
very beautiful, large orange.
And he was excited.
And he opened up the
orange, and it was all skin.
And there was just a
little bit in the middle.
He was saying it is like this.
It's all in the surface.
So if Professor Villiers had
an orange in 3N dimension,
he would have exponentially
hard time extracting an orange.
So this is our formula for
the entropy of this gas.
Essentially the
extensive parts, n log v
and something that
depends on n log E.
And that's really all
we need to figure out
all of the thermodynamic
properties,
because we said that
we can construct--
that's in thermodynamics--
dE is TdS minus PdV plus YdN
in the case of a gas.
And so we can
rearrange that to dS
be dE over T plus P over
T dV minus Y over T dN.
And the first thing
that we see is
by taking the derivative of S
with respect to the quantities
that we have
established, E, V, and N,
we should be able to read
off appropriate quantities.
And in particular,
let's say 1 over T
would be dS by dE
of constant v and n.
S will be proportional to kB.
And then they dependents
of this object on E
only appears on
this log E. Except
that there's a factor
of 3N over 2 out front.
And the derivative of log E
with respect to E is 1 over E.
So I can certainly
immediately rearrange
this and to get that
the energy is 3/2 N k
T in this system of ideal point
particles in three dimensions.
And then the
pressure, P over T, is
the S by dV at constant e and n.
And it's again, kB.
The only dependence on V
is through this N log V.
So I will get a factor of N over
V, which I can rearrange to PV
is N kB T by the ideal gas law.
And in principle,
the next step would
be to calculate the
chemical potential.
But we will leave that
for the time being
for reasons that
will become apparent.
Now, one thing to note is that
what you have postulated here,
right at the beginning, is
much, much, more information
than what we extracted here
about thermodynamic properties.
It's a statement about a
joint probability distribution
in this six N
dimensional face space.
So it has huge amount
of information.
Just to show you part
of it, let's take
a note at the following.
What it is a probability
as a function of all
coordinates and momenta
across your system.
But let me ask a
specific question.
I can ask what's the probability
that some particular particle--
say particle number
one-- has a momentum P1.
It's the only
question that I care
to ask about this huge
amount of degrees of freedom
that are encoded in P of mu.
And so what do I do if I
don't really care about all
of the other degrees of freedom
is I will integrate them.
So I don't really care where
particle number one is located.
I didn't ask where
it is in the box.
I don't really care where part
because numbers two through N
are located or which
momenta they have.
So I integrate over
all of those things
of the full joint
probability, which
depends on the entirety
of the face space.
Fine, you say, OK.
This joint probability actually
has a very simple form.
It is 1 over this
omega E, V, and N,
multiplying either 1 or 0.
So I have to integrate
over all of these q1's, all
of these qi P i.
Of 1 over omega or 0
over omega, this delta
like function that
we put in a box
up there-- so this is
this delta function that
says that the particular
should be inside the box.
And the sum of
the momenta should
be on the surface
of this hypershpere.
Now, let's do
these integrations.
Let's do it here.
I may need space.
The integration over
Q1 is very simple.
It will give me a factor of V.
I have this omega E, V,
N, in the denominator.
And I claim that the numerator
is simply the following.
Omega E minus P1 squared
over 2m V N minus 1.
Why?
Because what I need to do over
here in terms of integrations
is pretty much what I would
have to integrate over here
that gave rise to that surface
and all of those factors
with one exception.
First of all, I integrated
over one particle already,
so the coordinate momenta here
that I'm integrating pertains
to the remaining N minus 1.
Hence, the omega
pertains to N minus 1.
It's still in the
same box of volume V.
So V, the other
argument, is the same.
But the energy is changed.
Why?
Because I told you
how much momentum
I want the first
particle to carry.
So given the knowledge
that I'm looking
at the probability of the first
particle having momentum P1,
then I know that the
remainder of the energy
should be shared among the
momenta of all the remaining
N minus 1 particles.
So I have already calculated
these omegas up here.
All I need to do is to
substitute them over here.
And I will get this probability.
So first of all, let's check
that the volume part cancels.
I have one factor a volume here.
Each of my omegas is in fact
proportional to V to the N.
So the denominator
has V to the N.
The numerator has a
V to the N minus 1.
And all of the V's
would cancel out.
So the interesting thing really
comes from these solid angle
and radius parts.
The solid angle is a ratio of--
let's write the denominator.
It's easier.
It is 2 pi to the 3N over
2 divided by 3N over 2
minus one factorial.
The numerator would be 2
pi to the 3 N and minus 1
over 2 divided by 3 N minus
1 over 2 minus 1 factorial.
And then I have these
ratio of the radii.
In the denominator I have 2mE to
the power of 3 N minus 1 over 2
minus 1.
So minus 3N-- it is
3N minus 1 over 2.
Same thing that we have
been calculating so far.
And in the numerator it is 2m
E minus P1 squared over 2m.
So I will factor out the E.
I have 1 minus P1 squared
over 2m E. The whole
thing raised to something
that is 3 N minus
1 minus 1 over 2.
Now, the most
important part of this
is the fact that the dependence
on P1 appears as follows.
I have this factor of 1
minus P1 squared over 2m E.
That's the one place
that P1, the momentum
of the particle that
I'm interested appears.
And it raised to
the huge problem,
which is of the
order of 3N over 2.
It is likely less.
But it really doesn't
make any difference
whether I write 3N over 2, 3N
over minus 1 over 2, et cetera.
Really, ultimately,
what I will have
is 1 minus the very small
number, because presumably
the energy of one
part they can is
less than the energy of the
entirety of the particle.
So this is something that is
order of 1 out of N raised
to something that is
order of N. So that's
where an exponentiation
will come into play.
And then there's a whole
bunch of other factors
that if I don't make any
mistake I can try to write down.
There is the 2s
certainly cancel when
I look at the factors of pi.
The denominator with
respect to the numerator
has an additional
factor of pi to the 3/2.
In fact, I will
have a whole bunch
of things that are raised
to the powers of 3/2.
I also have this
2mE that compared
to the 2mE that
comes out front has
an additional factor of 3/2.
So let's put all
of them together.
2 pi mE raised to
the power of 3/2.
And then I have the ratio
of these factorials.
And again, the factorial that
I have in the denominator
has one and a half times
more or 3/2 times more
than what is in the numerator.
Roughly it is something
like the ratio
of 3 N over 2
factorial divided by 3
N minus 1 over 2 factorial.
And I claim that, say,
N factorial compared
to N minus 1 factorial is
larger by a factor of N.
If I go between N factorial
N minus 2 factorial is
a factor that is
roughly N squared.
Now this does not shift either
by 1 or by 2, but by 1 and 1/2.
And if you go through
Sterling formula, et cetera,
you can convince yourself that
this is roughly 3 N over 2
to the power of 1 and 1/2-- 3/2.
And so once you do all of your
arrangements, what do you get?
1 minus a small quantity
raised to a huge power,
that's the definition
of the exponential.
So I get exponential of
minus P1 squared over 2m.
And the factor that
multiplies it is E.
And then I have 3N over 2.
And again, if I have
not made any mistake
and I'm careful with all of
the other factors that remain,
I have here 2 pi m
E. And this E also
gets multiplied by the
inverse of 3N over 2.
So I will have this
replaced by 2E over 3N.
So statement number
one, this assignment
of probabilities according
to just throwing the dice
and saying that everything
that has the same right energy
is equally likely is
equivalent to looking
at one of the
particles and stating
that the momentum of that part
again is Gaussian distributed.
Secondly, you can check that
this combination, 2E divided
by 3N is the same thing as kT.
So essentially
this you could also
if you want to
replace 1 over kT.
And you would get the
more familiar kind
of Maxwell type of
distribution for the momentum
of a single particle
in an ideal gas.
And again, since
everything that we did
was consistent with the
laws of probability,
if we did not mix up the
orders of N, et cetera,
the answer should be
properly normalized.
And indeed, you can check that
this is the three dimensional
normalization that you
would require for this gas.
So the statement of saying
that everything is allowed
is equally likely is a
huge statement in space
of possible configurations.
On the one hand, it gives
you macroscopic information.
On the other hand, it
retains a huge amount
of microscopic information.
The parts of it
that are relevant,
you can try to
extract this here.
OK?
So those were the successes.
Question is why didn't
I calculate for you
this u over T?
It is because this
expression as we wrote down
has a glaring problem
with it, which in order
to make it explicit, we will
look at mixing entropies.
So the idea is
this is as follows.
Let's imagine that we
start with two gases.
Initially, I have N1 particles
of one type in volume 1.
And I have N2 particles of
another type in volume 2.
And for simplicity I will
assume that both of them
are of the same temperature.
So this is my initial state.
And then I remove the partition.
And I come up with
this situation
where the particles are mixed.
So the particles of type
1 could be either way.
Particles of type 2
could be in either place.
And let's say I have a box
of some toxic gas here.
And I remove the lid.
And it will get
mixed in the room.
It's certainly an
irreversible situation
where is an increase of
entropy i associated with that.
And we can calculate
that increase of entropy,
because we know what the
expression for entropy is.
So what we have to do is to
compare the entropy initially.
So this is the initial entropy.
And I calculate
everything in units of kB
so I don't have to write
kB all over the place.
For particle number
one, what do I have?
I have N1 log V1.
And then I have a contribution,
which is 3 N 1 over 2.
But I notice that whatever
appears here is really
only a function of
E over N. E over N
is really only a
function of temperature.
So this is something that I can
call a sigma of T over here.
And the contribution of box 2
is N2 log V plus 3N 2 over 2.
This-- huh-- let's
say that they are--
we ignore the
difference in masses.
You could potentially have
here sigma 1, sigma 2.
It really doesn't
make any difference.
The final state,
what do we have?
Essentially, the one
thing that changed
is that the N1 particles now
are occupying the box of volume
V. So if call V to the
V1 plus V2, what we have
is that we have N1 log
of V plus N2 log of V.
My claim is that all
of these other factors
really stay the same.
Because essentially what is
happening in these expressions
are various ratios of E over N.
And by stating that initially I
had the things at
the same temperature,
what I had effectively
stated was that E1 over N1
is the same thing as E2 over N2.
I guess in the ideal
gas case this E over N
is the same thing as 3/2 kT.
But if I have a
ratio such as this,
that is also the same as E1
plus E2 divided by N1 plus N2.
This is a simple manipulation
of fractions that I can make.
And E1 plus E2 over N1 plus N2,
by the same kinds of arguments,
would give me the
final temperature.
So what I have to compute is
that the final temperature
is the same thing as
the initial temperature.
Essentially, in this
mixing of the ideal gases,
temperature does not change.
So basically, these
factors of sigma
are the same before and after.
And so when we calculate
the increase in entropy, Sf
minus Si, really
the contribution
that you care about comes
from these volume factors.
And really the statement is
that in one particle currently
are occupying a
volume of size V,
whereas previously
they were in V1.
And similarly for
the N2 particles.
And if you have more of these
particles, more of these boxes,
you could see how the
general expression
for the mixing entropy goes.
And so that's fine.
V is certainly
greater than V1 or V2.
Each of these logs gives
you a positive contribution.
There's an increase in
entropy as we expect.
Now, there is the following
difficulty however.
What if the gases are
identical-- are the same?
We definitely have to do this
if I take a box of methane here
and I open it, we all know
that something has happened.
There is an irreversible
process that has occured.
But if the box--
I have essentially
taken the air in this
room, put it in this box,
whether I open the lid
or not open the lid,
it doesn't make any difference.
There is no
additional work that I
have to do in order to
close or open the lid.
Is no there no increase of
entropy one way or the other.
Whereas if I look
at this expression,
this expression only
depends on the final volume
and the initial
volumes, and says
that there should an
increase in entropy
when we know that
there shouldn't be.
And of course, the
resolution for that
is something like this.
That if I look at my two boxes--
and I said maybe one of them
is a box that contains methane.
Let's call it A.
And the other is
the room that contains the air.
Now this situation
where all of the methane
is in the box and the oxygen
freely floating in the room
is certainly different
from a configuration
where I exchange these two
and the methane is here
and the oxygen
went into the box.
They're different
configurations.
You can definitely
tell them apart.
Whereas if I do the same
thing, but the box and outside
contain the same entity, and
the same entity is, let's say,
oxygen, then how can you tell
apart these two configurations?
And so the meaning of-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you
thinking quantum
mechanically or classically.
Classically we can
tell them apart, right?
MEHRAN KARDAR:
This is currently I
am making a
macroscopic statement.
Now when I get to the
distinction of microstates
we have to-- so I was
very careful in saying
whether or not you
could tell apart
whether it is methane or oxygen.
So this was a very
macroscopic statement as to
whether or not you
can distinguish
this circumstance versus
that circumstance.
So as far as our senses of
this macroscopic process
is concerned, these two cases
have to be treated differently.
Now, what we have calculated
here for these factors
are some volume of phase space.
And where in the
evening you might
say that following
this procedure
you counted these as
two distinct cases.
In this case, these
were two distinct cases.
But here, you can't
really tell them apart.
So if you can't
tell them apart, you
shouldn't call them
two distinct cases.
You have over counted phase
space by a factor of two here.
And here, I just looked
at two particles.
If I have N
particles, I have over
counted the phase space
of identical particles
by all possible permutations of
n objects, it is n factorial.
So there is an over
counting of phase space
or configurations of
N identical particles
by a factor of N factorial.
I.e., when we said that particle
number one can be anywhere
in the box, particle
number two can be anywhere
in the box, all the way
to particle number n,
well, in fact, I can't
tell which each is which.
If I can't tell which
particle is which,
I have to divide by the number
of permutations and factors.
Now, as somebody was
asking the question,
as you were asking the
question, classically,
if I write a
computer program that
looks at the trajectories
of N particles
in the gas in this room,
classically, your computer
would always know the particle
that started over here
after many collisions
or whatever
is the particle that
ended up somewhere else.
So if you ask the
computer, the computer
can certainly distinguish
these classical trajectories.
And then it is kind of
strange to say that, well, I
have to divide by N factorial
because all of these
are identical.
Again, classically
these particles
are following
specific trajectories.
And you know where in
phase space they are.
Whereas quantum mechanically,
you can't tell that apart.
So quantum mechanically, as
we will describe later, rather
than classical statistical
mechanics-- when
we do quantum statistical
mechanics-- if you have
identical particles,
you have to write down
of a wave function that
is either symmetric or
anti-symmetric under the
exchange of particles.
And when we do eventually
the calculations
for these factors of
1 over N factorial
will emerge very naturally.
So I think different people
have different perspectives.
My own perspective is
that this factor really
is due to the quantum
origin of identity.
And classically, you have to
sort of fudge it and put it
over there.
But some people say that really
it's a matter of measurements.
And if you can't really tell
A and B sufficiently apart,
then you don't know.
I always go back
to the computer.
And say, well, the
computer can tell.
But it's kind of
immaterial at this stage.
It's obvious that for all
practical purposes for things
that are identical you have
to divide by this factor.
So what happens if you
divide by that factor?
So I have changed all
of my calculations now.
So when I do the log of--
previously I had V to the N.
And it gave me N log
V. Now, I have log of V
to the N divided by N factorial.
So I will get my Sterling's
approximation additional factor
of minus N log N plus N, which
I can sort of absorb here
in this fashion.
Now you say, well, having
done that, you have to first
of all show me that you
fixed the case of this change
in entropy for
identical particles,
but also you should show me
that the previous case where
we know there has to be an
increase in entropy just
because of the gas being
different that that is not
changed because of this
modification that you make.
So let's check that.
So for distinct gases, what
would be the generalization
of this form Sf minus
Si divided by kV?
Well, what happens here?
In the case of the final object,
I have to divide N1 log of V.
But that V really becomes
V divided by N1, because
in the volume of size
V, I have N1 oxygen
that I can't tell apart.
So I divide by the N1
factorial for the oxygens.
And then I have N2 methanes
that I can't tell apart
in that volume, so I divide by
essentially N2 factorial that
goes over there.
The initial change is over
here I would have N1 log of V1
over N1.
And here I would have
had N2 log of V2 over N2.
So every one of these
expressions that was previously
log V, and I had four
of them, gets changed.
But they get change precisely in
a manner that this N1 log of N1
here cancels this N1
log of and N1 here.
This N2 log of N2 here cancels
this N2 log of N2 here.
So the delta S that I get
is precisely the same thing
as I had before.
I will get N1 log of V over
V1 plus N2 log of V over V2.
So this division,
because the oxygens were
identical to
themselves and methanes
were identical to
themselves, does not
change the mixing entropy
of oxygen and nitrogen.
But let's say that both
gases are the same.
They're both oxygen.
Then what happens?
Now, in the final
state, I have a box.
It has a N1 plus N2 particles
that are all oxygen.
I can't tell them apart.
So the contribution
from the phase space
would be N1 plus N2 log of the
volume divided by N1 plus N2
factorial.
That ultimately will give me
a factor of N1 plus N2 here.
The initial entropy
is exactly the one
that I calculated before.
For the line above,
I have N1 log of V1
over N1 minus N2
log of V2 over N2.
Now certainly, I still expect
to see some mixing entropy
if I have a box of oxygen
that is at very low pressure
and is very dilute,
and I open it
into this room, which is
at much higher pressure
and is much more dense.
So really, the
case where I don't
expect to see any
change in entropy
is when the two boxes
have the same density.
And hence, when I mix
them, I would also
have exactly the same density.
And you can see that, therefore,
all of these factors that
are in the log are of the
inverse of the same density.
And there's N1 plus N2
of them that's positive.
And N1 plus N2 of
them that is negative.
So the answer in
this case, as long
as I try to mix identical
particles of the same density,
if I include this
correction to the phase
space of identical
particles, the answer
will be [? 0. ?] Yes?
AUDIENCE: Question,
[INAUDIBLE] in terms
of the revolution
of the [INAUDIBLE]
there is no
transition [INAUDIBLE]
so that your temporary, and say
like, oxygen and nitrogen can
catch a molecule, put it
in a [? aspertometer. ?]
and have different isotopes.
You can take like closed
isotopes of oxygen
and still tell them apart.
But this is like
their continuous way
of choosing a pair
of gases which
would be arbitrarily
closed in atomic mass.
MEHRAN KARDAR: So,
as I said, there
are alternative explanations
that I've heard.
And that's precisely
one of them.
And my counter is that
what we are putting here
is the volume of phase space.
And to me that has a
very specific meaning.
That is there's a set of
coordinates and momenta
that are moving according
to Hamiltonian trajectories.
And in principle, there
is a computer nature
that is following
these trajectories,
or I can actually put
them on the computer.
And then no matter
how long I run
and they're identical
oxygen molecules,
I start with number one
here, numbers two here.
The computer will say that this
is the trajectory of number one
and this is the
trajectory of numbers two.
So unless I change my
definition of phase space
and how I am calculating
things, I run into this paradox.
So what you're saying
is forget about that.
It's just can tell isotopes
apart or something like that.
And I'm saying that that's fine.
That's perspective,
but it has nothing
to do with phase space counting.
OK?
Fine, now, why didn't
I calculate this?
It was also for the
same reason, because we
expect to have quantities
that are extensive
and quantities
that are intensive.
And therefore, if I
were to, for example,
calculate this object,
that it should be something
that is intensive.
Now the problem is that if I
take a derivative with respect
N, I have log V.
And log V is clearly
something that does not
grow proportionately to size
but grows proportionately
to size logarithmically.
So if I make volume
twice as big,
I will get an additional factor
of log 2 here contribution
to the chemical potential.
And that does not make sense.
But when I do this identity,
then this V becomes V over N.
And then everything
becomes nicely intensive.
So if I allowed now to
replace this V over N,
then I can calculate V over T
as dS by dN at constant E and V.
And so then
essentially I will get
to drop the factor of log N that
comes in front, so I will get
kT log of V over
N. And then I would
have 3/2 log of something, which
I can put together as 4 pi N
E over 3N raised
to the 3/2 power.
And you can see that
there were these E's
from Sterling's
approximation up there that
got dropped here, because
you can also take derivative
with respect to the
N's that are inside.
And you can check that the
function of derivatives
with respects to the
N's that are inside
is precisely to get
rid of those factors.
OK?
Now, there is still
one other thing
that is not wrong, but
kind of like jarring
about the expressions
that they've
had so far in that right
from the beginning,
I said that you can certainly
calculate entropies out
of probabilities as minus
log of P average if you like.
But it makes sense
only if you're
dealing with discrete
variables, because when you're
dealing with continual
variables and you
have a probability density.
And the probability
density depends
on the units of measurement.
And if you were to change
measurement from meters
to centimeters or
something else,
then there will be changes
in the probability densities,
which would then modify the
various factors over here.
And that's really also
is reflected ultimately
in the fact that these
combinations of terms
that I have written
here have dimensions.
And it is kind
of, again, jarring
to have expressions inside the
logarithm or in the exponential
that our not dimensionless.
So it would be good
if we had some way
of making all of
these dimensionless.
And you say, well,
really the origin of it
is all the way back
here, when I was
calculating volumes
in phase space.
And volumes in phase
space have dimensions.
And that dimensions of
pq raised to the 3N power
really survives all
the way down here.
So I can say, OK, I
choose some quantity
as a reference that has the
right dimensions of the product
of p and q, which is an action.
And I divide all
of my measurements
by that reference unit, so
that, for example, here I
have 3N factors of this.
Or let's say each
one of them is 3.
I divide by some quantity
that has units of action .
And then I will be set.
So basically, the units of this
h is the product of p and q.
Now, at this point
we have no way
of choosing some h as
opposed to another h.
And so by adding that factor,
we can make things look nicer.
But then things are undefined
after this factor of h.
When we do quantum
mechanics, another thing
that quantum mechanics
does is to provide us
with precisely [? age ?] of
Planck's constant as a measure
of these kinds of integrations.
So when we eventually
you go to calculate, say,
the ideal gas or any
other mechanic system
that involves p and q
in quantum mechanics,
then the phase space
becomes discretized.
You would have-- The
appropriate description
would have energies that are
discretized corresponding
to various other discretization
that are eventually
the equivalent to dividing
by this Planck's constant.
Ultimately, I will
have additionally
a factor of h squared
appearing here.
And it will make everything
nicely that much [? less. ?]
None of these other quantities
that I mentioned calculated
would be affected by this.
So essentially,
what I'm saying is
that you are going to
use a measure for phase
space of identical particles.
Previously we had a product,
d cubed Pi, d cubed Qi.
This is what we were
integrating and requiring
that this integration
will give us [INAUDIBLE].
Now, we will change this to
divide by this N factorial,
if the particles are identical.
And we divide by h
to the 3N because
of the number of pairs of
pq that appear in this.
The justification to come when
we ultimately do quantum study.
Any questions?
So I said that this
prescription when
we look at a system
at complete isolation,
and therefore, specify
fully its energy
is the microcanonical
ensemble, as opposed
to the canonical
ensemble, whereas the set
of microscopic parameters
that you identified
with your system, you replace
the energy with temperature.
So in general,
let's say there will
be some bunch of
displacements, x, that give you
the work content to the system.
Just like we fixed over there
the volume and the number
of particles, let's say that
all of the work parameters,
such as x
microscopically, we will
fix in this canonical ensemble.
So however, the
ensemble is one in which
the energy is not specified.
And so how do I
imagine that I can
maintain a system
at temperature T?
Well, if this room is at
some particular temperature,
I assume that smaller objects
that I put in this room
will come to the
same temperature.
So the general prescription
for beginning something other
than temperature T is
to put it in contact
with something that
is much bigger.
So let's call this
to be a reservoir.
And we put our system, which
we assume to be smaller,
in contact with it.
And we allow it to exchange
heat with the reservoir.
Now I did this way of
managing the system
to come to a
temperature T, which
is the characteristic
of a big reservoir.
Imagine that you have a lake.
And you put your gas or
something else inside the lake.
And it will equilibrate to
the temperature of the lake.
I will assume that
the two of them,
the system and the
reservoir, just
for the purpose of my being
able to do some computation,
are isolated from the
rest of the universe,
so that the system plus
reservoir is microcanonical.
And the sum total of their
energies is sum E total.
So now this system still
is something like a gas.
It's a has a huge number of
potential degrees of freedom.
And these potential number
of degrees of freedom
can be captured through the
microstate of the system,
u sub s.
And similarly, the water
particle in the lake
have their own state.
An there's some
microstate that describes
the positions and the momenta
of all of the particles
that are in the lake.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you're writing
the set of particles used
to describe it, why
don't you write N?
Since it said the number
of particles in the system
is not fixed.
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes, so I
did want to [INAUDIBLE]
but in principle I could add N.
I wanted to be kind of general.
If you like X,
[? it ?] is allowed
to include chemical
work type of an X.
So what do I know?
I know that there is also if
I want to describe microstates
and their revolution,
I need to specify
that there's a
Hamiltonian that governs
the evolution of
these microstates.
And presumably
there's a Hamiltonian
that describes the evolution
of the reservoir microstate.
And so presumably the
allowed microstates
are ones in which
E total is made up
of the energy of the system plus
the energy of the reservoir.
So because the whole thing
is the microcanonical,
I can assign a probability,
a joint probability,
to finding some particular
mu s, mu r combination,
just like we were
doing over there.
You would say that
essentially this
is a combination
of these 1s and 0s.
So it is 0 if H of--
again, for simplicity I
drop the s on the
system-- H of mu s plus H
reservoir of mu reservoir
is not equal to E total.
And it is 1 over some omega
of reservoir in the system
otherwise.
So this is just again,
throwing the dice,
saying that it has so many
possible configurations, given
that I know what
the total energy is.
All the ones that are consistent
with that are allowed.
Which is to say, I don't
really care about the lake.
All I care is about to
the states of my gas,
and say, OK, no problem, if
I have the joint probability
distribution just
like I did over here,
I get rid of all of
the degrees of freedom
that I'm not interested in.
So if I'm interested only
in the states of the system,
I sum over or integrate
over-- so this would be a sum.
This would be an
integration, whatever--
of the joint probability
distribution.
Now actually follow the
steps that I had over here
when we were looking at the
momentum of a gas particle.
I say that what
I have over here,
this probability see
is this 1 over omega R,
S. This is a function
that is either 1 or 0.
And then I have so sum
over all configurations
of the reservoir.
But given that I said what
the microstate of the system
is, then I know that the
reservoir has to take energy
in total minus the amount
the microstates has taken.
And I'm summing over all
of the microstates that
are consistent with
the requirement
that the energy in
the reservoir is
E total minus H of microstate.
So what that is that
the omega that I
have for the reservoir--
and I don't know what it is,
but whatever it is,
evaluated at the total energy
minus the energy that is
taken outside the microstate.
So again, exactly the reason
why this became E minus Pi
squared over 2.
This becomes E total
minus H of mu S. Except
that I don't know either
what this is or what this is.
Actually, I don't really
even care about this
because all of the H dependents
on microstate dependents
is in the numerator.
So I write that as
proportional to exponential.
And the log of omega
is the entropy.
So I have the entropy of the
[INAUDIBLE] in units of kB,
evaluated at the argument that
this E total minus H of mu S.
So my statement is
that when I look
at the entropy of the
reservoir as a function of E
total minus the energy
that is taken out
by the system, my
construction I assume
that I'm putting a small
volume of gas in contact
with a huge lake.
So this total energy is
overwhelmingly larger
than the amount of energy
that the system can occupy.
So I can make a Taylor
expansion of this quantity
and say that this is S R of E
total minus the derivative of S
with respect to its energy.
So the derivative
of the S reservoir
with respect to the energy
of the reservoir times
H of the microstate and
presumably higher order terms
that are negligible.
Now the next thing that is
important about the reservoir
is you have this huge lake.
Let's say it's exactly at some
temperature of 30 degrees.
And you take some small
amount of energy from it
to put in the system.
The temperature of the
lake should not change.
So that's the definition
of the reservoir.
It's a system that is so big
that for the range of energies
that we are considering,
this S by dE
is 1 over the temperature that
characterizes the reservoir.
So just like here,
but eventually
the answer that we
got was something
like the energy of the
particle divided by kT.
Once I exponentiate, I
find that the probability
to find the system in some
microstate is proportional to E
to the minus of the energy of
that microstate divided by kT.
And of course, there's
a bunch of other things
that I have to eventually
put into a normalization that
will cause.
So in the canonical
prescription you sort of replace
this throwing of
the dice and saying
that everything is equivalent
to saying that well,
each microstates can have
some particular energy.
And the probabilities
are partitioned according
to the Boltzmann weights
of these energies.
And clearly this quantity,
Z, the normalization
is obtained by integrating
over the entire space
of microstates, or
summing over them
if they are discrete of this
factor of E to the minus beta
H of mu S. And we'll use
this notation beta 1 over kT
sometimes for simplicity.
Now, the thing is that
thermodynamically, we
said that you can choose
any set of parameters,
as long as they are
independent, to describe
the macroscopic equilibrium
state of the system.
So what we did in the
microcanonical ensemble is
we specified a number of
things, such as energy.
And we derived the other
things, such as temperature.
So here, in the
canonical ensemble,
we have stated what the
temperature of the system is.
Well, then what happened?
On one hand, maybe we have
to worry because energy
is constantly being
exchanged with the reservoir.
And so the energy of the system
does not have a specific value.
There's a probability for it.
So probability of
system having energy
epsilon-- it doesn't
have a fixed energy.
There is a probability
that it should have energy.
And this probability,
let's say we indicate
with P epsilon given that
we know what temperature is.
Well, on one hand we
have this factor of E
to the minus epsilon over kT.
That comes from the [INAUDIBLE].
But there isn't a single
state that has that energy.
There's a whole
bunch of other states
of the system that
have that energy.
So as I scan the
microstates, there
will be a huge number of them,
omega of epsilon in number,
that have this right energy.
And so that's the
probability of the energy.
And I can write this
as E to the minus 1
over kT that I've called beta.
I have epsilon.
And then the log of
omega that I take
in the numerator
is S divided by Kb.
I can take that Kb here and
write this as T S of epsilon.
And so this kind of
should remind you
of something like a free energy.
But it tells you is
that this probability
to have some particular energy
is some kind of [? a form. ?]
Now note that again for
something like a gas
or whatever, we expect typical
values of both the energy
and entropy to be
quantities that
are proportional to
the size of the system.
As the size of the system
becomes exponentially large,
we would expect that
this probability would
be one of those things
that has portions that
let's say are exponentially
larger than any other portion.
There will be a factor of
E to the minus N something
that will really peak up,
let's say, the extremum
and make the extremum
overwhelmingly more likely
than other places.
Let's try to quantify
that a little bit better.
Once we have a
probability, we can also
start calculating averages.
So let's define what the
average energy of the system is.
The average energy
of the system is
obtained by summing
over all microstates.
The energy of that
microstate, the probability
of that microstate, which
is E to the minus beta H
microstate divided by the
partition function, which
is the sum-- OK,
the normalization,
which we will call the
partition function, which
is the sum over all
of these microstates.
Now this is something
that we've already seen.
If I look at this expression
in the denominator
that we call Z and has a
name, which is the partition
function, then it's
certainly a function of beta.
If I take a derivative of Z with
respect to beta, what happens
I'll bring down a
factor of H over here.
So the numerator up to
a sine is the derivative
of Z with respect to beta.
And the denominator is 1 over
Z. And so this is none other
than minus the log Z
with respect to beta.
So OK, fine, so the mean
value of this probability
is given by some
expression such as this.
Well, you can see that if I
were to repeat this process
and rather than
taking one derivative,
I will take n derivatives
and then divide by 1 over Z.
Each time I do that, I will
bring down a factor of H.
So this is going to give me
the average of H to the N.
The end moment of this
probability distribution
of energy is obtainable
by this procedure.
So now you recognize, oh, I've
seen things like such as this.
So clearly this
partition function
is something that
generates the moments
by taking subsequent
derivatives.
I can generate different
moments of this distribution.
But then there
was something else
that maybe this
should remind you,
which is that if there's
a quantity that generates
moments, then its log
generates cumulants.
So you would say,
OK, the nth cumulant
should be obtainable up to this
factor of minus 1 to the n,
as the nth derivative with
respect to the beta of logs.
And it's very easy
to check that indeed
if I were to take
two derivatives,
I will get the
expectation value of H
squared minus the average
of H squared, et cetera.
But the point is that
clearly this to log Z
is, again, something
that is extensive.
Another way of getting
the normalization-- I
guess I forgot to put
this 1 over Z here.
So now it is a perfectly
normalized object.
So another way to get
z would be to look
at the normalization
of the probability.
I could integrate over epsilon
this factor of E to the minus
beta epsilon minus
T S of epsilon.
And that would give
me Z. Now, again
the quantities that appear
in the exponent, energy--
entropy, their
difference, free energy--
are quantities
that are extensive.
So this Z is going
to be dominated again
by where this peak is.
And therefore, log of Z
will be proportional to log
of what we have over here.
And it be an extensive quantity.
So ultimately, my statement
is that this log of Z
is something that is order of N.
So we are, again,
kind of reminiscent
of the central limit theorem.
In a situation where we have
a probability distribution,
at large N, in which
all of the cumulants
are proportional to N. The
mean is proportional to N.
The variance is proportional
to N. All of the cumulants
are proportional
to N, which means
that essentially the extent of
the fluctuations that you have
over here are going to go the
order of the square root of N.
So the bridge, the thing
that again allows us,
while we have in principle in
the expression that we have
said, a variable
energy for the system.
In fact, in the limit of
things becoming extensive,
I know where that energy
is, up to fluctuations
or up to uncertainty
that is only
of the order of
square root of N.
And so the relative uncertainty
will vanish as the N goes
to infinity, limit
is approached.
So although again
we have something
that is in principle
probabilistic,
again, in the
thermodynamic sense
we can identify uniquely an
energy for our system as,
let's say, the mean value
or the most likely value.
They're all the same thing
of the order of 1 over N.
And again, to be more
precise, the variance
is clearly the second derivative
of log Z. 1 derivative of a log
Z is going to give
me the energy.
So this is going to
be d by d beta up
to a minus sign of the
energy or the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian,
which we identified
as the energy of the system.
The derivative with
respect to beta,
I can write as kB T squared.
The derivative of energy
with respect to T,
everything here we are doing
that conditions of no work.
So the variance is
in fact kB T squared,
the heat capacity of the system.
So the extent that these
fluctuations squared
is kB T squared times the
heat capacity the system.
OK, so next time
what we will do is
we will calculate the
results for the ideal gas.
First thing, the
canonical ensemble
to show that we get exactly
the same macroscopic
and microscopic descriptions.
And then we look
at other ensembles.
And that will
conclude the segment
that we have on
statistical mechanics
of non-interacting systems.